geschenkt
ich denke dass mit bomber hoffen dass
auch ein scherz oder alex ich dachte wir
machen die macht uns leider nicht
spätestens um 12 täglich nach hause
leben fit und ausgeschlafen sein für den
termin heißt das mit solar maschine
stimmt auch was denn ohne dass du dich
etwas geredet
wir machen die gesamte pr für einen
hersteller von solaranlagen und ich habe
ihr erzählt dass der geschäftsführer
wegen unterschlagener verhaftet worden
sein
nicht gemeint ich bin voll drauf
reingefallen gratuliere richtig kreativ
bekam eine fahrrad geschichte nicht
mithalten
für meinen geschmack hatte ich noch ein
bisschen souveräner sein können
wer will noch sechs aber nicht
überzeugend gericht du bist du
leichtgläubig gut zu tun vertraute blind
alex so kann man das aussehen richtig
lecker
du kannst dich löwen so gut aber
immerhin selbst gekommen
zum backen fehlt die zeit für mich offen
wo es also wenn ihr einer keine zeit hat
dann ist das ein probe hier konzert da
wenn du ständig im büro wuchs dann kann
ich und kuchen es konnte ja keiner
wissen dass wir mit alex wenn zur
durchstarten
auch dank der toto wenn man erfolg haben
will muss man eben abstriche machen wenn
ich wenigstens davon hätte das motto
karriere oft wenn george am morgen bei
brückmann media überzeugt dann lässt du
dich bestimmt zum essen ein
das könnte ein riesending werden ich bin
sicher dass alle um den finger wickelt
entschuldige wir kennen uns noch gar
nicht ich bin alex geschäftspartner von
giotto den schwestern ich wohl
übergangsweise bei ihm und lotta die
betonung liegt auf übergangsweise also
weil ich heute so geärgert habt wünsche
ich mir jetzt ein geburtstagsständchen
glaubt mir das wissen mich wirklich wie
soll sinkt so nicht alleine
warum muss ich immer sehen du kannst du
das machst du mit links du bist bei 16
oder das kann man so sagen ihr seid echt
gut
ich war letztens meinem konzert von euch
und habt ihr euer album heruntergeladen
du hast schon recht bekannt langsam
wird's also was ist denn nun mit einem
geburtstagsständchen
du hast alle singen mit ich komme gleich